nous avons confié à des experts la
mission complexe de nous présenter trois
des découvertes archéologiques les plus
marquantes au canada christian gates
saint-pierre s'intéresse
particulièrement aux premiers habitants
qui ont peuplé le pays
selon lui le site de nice ou là sur la
côte nord est un incontournable parce
qu'on y retrouve des pets sur ubs
vieille de plus de deux mille ans le
faux s'imagine être sûr sur un lac on
est sur un lac dans un canoë on arrive
devant une paroi rocheuse une immense
paroi rocheuse qui surplombe une section
du lac et sur laquelle il ya des
peintures rupestres donc des peintures
en fait avec de l'autre rouge qui est
intéressant aussi c'est que ça donne un
accès à tout ce qui est cet été qui est
symbolique pour ces populations là car
les deux noms tels président d'arc et au
québec s'intéresse au phare ville marie
situé en plein coeur de montréal
peut-être un site emblématique pour
quiconque s'intéresse à l'histoire de
retrouver les traces de ceux qui sont
arrivés ici pour pour coloniser le pays
mais si c'est hautement émotif
finalement marie-jo gotti bérubé est
spécialisée dans l'archéologie
subaquatique au nunavut
les vestiges d'une expédition importante
dans l'histoire du canada la passionne
alors l'alchimiste erreur airbus ce sont
des navires de l'expédition franklin
donc une exposition qui est parti en
1845 de l'angleterre le but est de
trouver le passage du nord ouest donc le
passage à travers l'article et
éventuellement au 26ème c'est qu'on va
retrouver des traces terrestre jusqu'en
ce qu'on va retrouver le premier navire
puis en 2016 le deuxième est
l'instrument les des documents
historiques mais l'archéologie
maintenant nous permet de voir la partie
qui n'a jamais été écrite le monde de
l'archéologie est en pleine évolution et
des découvertes
il y en aura encore beaucoup les
sonneurs surtout nous permettre en fait
de découvrir des très grandes distances
et de voir sous l'eau
sans avoir envoyé deux plongeurs à ce
qui me concerne je dirais que le
principal changement c'est de faire de
l'archéologie avec les communautés
autochtones donc de les intégrer dans
nos dans nos démarches de fouiller des
sites qui les intéressent avec des
questions qui les intéressent
l'archéologue le plus célèbre a
contribué à faire connaître le métier
mais on a déformé la réalité on est loin
d'un diana jones ne sais pas l'aventuré
commence à imaginer d'autres types d'
aventure c'est de la science et de
l'exploration donc on on excelle sur le
métier qui est quand même fascinant qui
sort un peu de l'ordinaire donc nos
journées sont pas banales mais on n'est
pas toujours en train de poursuivre des
méchants nazis dans le fin fond de
l'amazonie et la beauté avec
l'archéologie c'est que des fouilles
partout au pays
yaurait 11007 au québec seulement ici
n'a dit alexandre charti radio canada
montréal